avec nous ce soir valérie plantes la
mairesse de montréal bonsoir madame
plantes non sera un plaisir de vous
accueillir à l'émission ce soir pour
parler de ce plan de relance
22 millions pour une économie faut dire
montréal qui est quand même malmené en
quoi votre plan faut faire une
différence cet été pour les commerces
pour la culture pour le tourisme et
effectivement c'est un le 22 millions
c'est vraiment pour un plan à court
terme parce que on va voir comment avec
l'évolution de la commune mais aussi en
ayant plus de données sur l'économie où
commence à la une et pacte est négatif
sur l'économie on va se réajuste
également mais ce qu'on souhaitait
vraiment c'est d'offrir des via des
subventions et de l'aide des règles
soutenir les petits commerçants nous
entreprenons mais surtout les plus
petits joueurs qui ont la vie dure et
magri les sommes d'argent qui ont été
décidées par les gouvernements
supérieurs mais qui sont surtout sous
forme sous forme de prêts alors nous on
est là on a vraiment ciblé des mesures
très particulière dans différents
domaines grâce à un comité d'experts de
tous les milieux et on veut vraiment et
c'est ça le but concession depuis
l'opération mais en 5 à montréal
les tv difficile que pourquoi les
touristes viendraient à montréal alors
que nous festival sont annulés
les événements attractif de montréal ne
sont pas là donc comment on fait pour
repartir la machine économique à
montréal cet été
en fait justement je pense que la une de
mes intentions c'est vraiment de garder
à flot de garder en vie le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises possible qui pour
qui c'est très difficile puis qui voit
très bien qu'on reporte tombé à la
normale pour les raisons que vous avez
évoqué que ce soit le pod et le fait
qu'ils aillent pas de festival où
beaucoup moins touriste avait presque
pour le touriste si je peux dire
donc l'idée c'est de les garder à flot
mais de suscite également un engouement
et de susciter l'achat local de vue que
les moyens les montréalaises fréquentent
leurs artères commerciales locales
on veut susciter on va en profiter si je
peux dire saisir l'opportunité pour
encourager le tout ce qui touche le
les industries circulaire on veut
pouvoir soutenir également les artères
commerciales locales viennent politique
de vie nocturne
donc on est vraiment dans penser à
l'extérieur de la boîte qui jusqu à date
je pense que c'est ce qui va réussir
parce que même les entrepreneurs les
commerçants le disent il faut qu'il se
réinvente un peu contre quoi on doit
s'adapter mais il ya des commerçants qui
s'inquiètent de tous les stationnements
qui ont été enlevés parce que vous avez
beaucoup développé les voies cyclables
et piétonnières vous avez annoncé 320 km
de plus si je me trompe pas au mois de
mai mais il y en a qui disent en même
temps il ya des gens qui hésitent à
reprendre le transport en commun est ce
que c'est le bon moment de poursuivre
cette politique de retirer certains
stationnements mais écoutez la
le fait de retirer du stationnement
c'est vraiment une évaluation de coparc
par exemple il ya des artères
commerciales locales comme la rue
wellington où l'avenue du mont-royal qui
ont pris la décision à deux concerts
avec leur société de développement
commercial pour paul oublié d'enlever
des places de stationnement mais surtout
de rendre la rue piétonne dans d'autres
rues commerciales c'est autre chose
alors on s'adapte
et au final c'est le fait de laisser
plus d'espacé entre autres et en
enlevant des places de stationnement
faut pas l'oublier c'est aussi pour
soutenir les restaurateurs et les bars
qui eux vont souhaite pouvoir faire des
affaires fructueuses le plus rapidement
possible oui exactement donc c'est le 2
mai est difficile à respecter à montréal
les terrasses etc j'ai l'impression
c'est ce qui nous reste à nous les
montréalais pour profiter de l'été c'est
d'aller s'asseoir sur un terreau à ce
qu'on veut le faire en sécurité
alors on donne de la place aux
commerçants ou auto nanciers de bars et
de restaurants
vous demandez aussi au gouvernement vous
avez retenu lorsque le goût de bouza de
vivre demandé au gouvernement de me
permettre de faire des déficits
budgétaires 1 pour consentir quoi des
allègements fiscaux supplémentaires aux
montréalais différentes options sont sur
la table d'ailleurs je rencontrais
ministre physique est bonne ce vendredi
donc on a pas mal de choses à discuter
mais faut comprendre que pour moi il
n'est pas question de demander de faire
des mises et un déficit pour payer
l'épicerie
pas de ça dans ces questions l'idée
c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut
accélérer accélérer certains
investissements pour que ça sert de
levier pour stimuler l'économie pour
aider justement notre économie locale
alors si plutôt dans cet ordre là quand
je parle de la capacité ou la
possibilité de faire un déficit c'est
vraiment de cette façon pour le voir
lorsque je suis vous pouvez pas faire de
déficit et les villes ne peuvent pas
faire de déficit vous avez un manque à
gagner important vous feriez quoi
autrement vous vous seriez obligés de
monter les taxes je dis souvent que avec
déficit anticipé pour montréal si j'ai
un transport collectif ça peut
facilement aller à 500 millions de
dollars
ça s'est passé à ce moment ci je vous
dirais qu on y est on s'y rapproche
dangereusement de ses déficits
alors à ce moment là oui c'est soit
couper dans les services ou augmenter
les taxes ou même les 2 500 millions
c'est ces énormes que vous devez québec
fla une ouverture et une ouverture à
comment je dirais une facilité la vie
mais en même temps ça c'est des sujets
qui même s'ils peuvent être alléchant où
semble intéressant faut toujours voir
également ce que ce que ça peut donner
sur le court terme mais également sur le
long terme alors les discussions qui ont
lieu en ce moment moi je les trouve très
intéressante et des éléments qu'on
demande au gouvernement du québec depuis
longtemps qu'il ya une porte qui s'ouvre
et je pense que ça vaut la peine
d'explorer de nouvelles avenues jean
leclant d'aujourd'hui vous dites qu'une
grande présence d'emploi propice au
télétravail dans le centre ville
on sent que c'est vraiment pas tout le
monde qui vont revenir au centre ville
fait quoi l'avenir du centre-ville de
montréal si le télétravail prend
beaucoup d'ampleur et que beaucoup de
bureaux qui restent vides
il ya en travaillant avec notre comité
aviseur dont plusieurs donneurs de
travail dans les grands tours à montréal
les chiffres qui reviennent souvent bien
concentrés les documenter c'est à peu
près un tiers des employés qui veulent
rester à la maison un tiers qui veut
absolument revenir au bureau qui en
retire à peu près qui serait fait à
moitié moitié et de là l'importance
d'avoir de travailler avec des personnes
comme michel leblanc ou encore madame
madame smart du
partenariat du quartier des spectacles
pour réfléchir de façon intégrée à
comment est ce qu'on trouve cet
équilibre entre encourager le travail le
télétravail qui peut être une bonne
chose au niveau environnemental même
pour s'assurer qu'elles moins de trafic
pourquoi faure et pour des questions de
santé publique
mais il faut aussi jumelé soa centre
ville qui est bon ce qui fait vibrer
toute la région
les commerçants dépendent de ces
travailleurs dans les tours so lu ment
absolument il faut trouver un équilibre
il n'est pas simple surtout qu'on sait
toujours pas par exemple est ce que on
va avoir une deuxième bague
comment vont réagir les grands
employeurs et comme je disais même lit
les employés donc de là l'importance
d'animer notre centre-ville moi j'ai
très heureuse travail qui est fait en ce
moment de dire ok conscient des primes
centre-ville on va le rendre piéton vol
animé pour que les gens ils reviennent
ayant même temps comme vous l'avez dit
la question du transport collective et
du transport actif demeure entière 2000
et envie de le prendre
dernier mot vous parlez de la ligne
bleue de la ligne rose page 24 de votre
plan de relance qu'un président du
conseil du trésor dit que ça le projet
de loi 61
oubliez ça la ligne bleue oubliez ça la
ligne bleue est ce que le report de
l'adoption du projet doivent ralentir la
reprise mais vous savez le projet de loi
en tant que tel pourrait être l h mais
ya définitivement des choses qui peuvent
être travaillés et qu'on peut mettre de
l'avant sans avoir le projet de loi en
tant que tel et l'expropriation en est
un des éléments
c'est un sujet dont on parle beaucoup
nous les municipalités même depuis la
négociation du pacte fiscal le dernier
pascal des municipalités on demande
qu'on revoie les règles alors on n'a pas
besoin du projet de loi dans son
entièreté pour avancer sur cette
question là bon on verra bien valérie
plan merci beaucoup merci au revoir